you know I've seen in some discourse
here in other places when discussing the
film in the morning particularly talking
about particular character people seem
to be befuddled at least briefly about
proper pronoun use
because the Moon is being a shapeshifter
and does flatly present masculine at
least once
people
get confused
they're settling on they I'm not sure if
it's a majority but a decent number of
them and I mean that makes sense right I
mean they're shifting genders pneumonia
isn't staying one thing and clearly
becomes a boy at one point so if we're
not going to change the pronoun for
every individual presentation we just
use they as a blanket thing that makes
sense right yeah that makes sense
but pneumonia doesn't object to she
she never corrects anybody she doesn't
wince when she hears people refer to her
as she if you want another point of
reference for non-binary with she her
pronouns Jenna from the good place not a
girl still except she it's okay